le bilan s'alourdit en montagne 11 albi
on trouvait la mort dans les alpes ces
trois derniers jours
le parquet de lyon se pourvoit en
cassation contre l'arrêt de la cour
d'appel qui considère la scientologie
comme une religion
le rapport sur l'immigration commandé
par le gouvernement préconise de
maintenir la demande volontaire de
naturalisation pour les enfants de
parents étrangers mais bel est maire
mais aussi lé père fumeurs peuvent
fragiliser la santé de leur bébé
selon les premiers résultats d'une
enquête américaine madame monsieur
bonsoir
la série noire continue dans les alpes
deux alpinistes sont encore portées
disparues aujourd'hui le bilan s'établit
à 11 morts en trois jours dont huit dans
la seule partie française dans le massif
du mont blanc
le beau temps qui règne actuellement sur
la région a fait affluer les candidats
l'escaladent qui sont plusieurs milliers
à se présenter chaque jour pour des
rambos randonnée comportant toujours une
part de danger
yves guyot thierry simonet affluence
record une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui sur
les sommets de chamonix le soleil était
au rendez vous alors quelques 5 à 6000
personnes n'ont pas hésité à se lancer
dans l'aventuré de la haute montagne
ascension de toutes les arêtes du mas
isc mais aussi et surtout ascension du
mont-blanc et de ses mythiques 4807 m
parmi les alpinistes beaucoup de
montagnards chevronnés mais aussi
beaucoup trop de touristes mal préparée
et mal équipés ce mont blanc c'est fou
ça des moments ça me dépasse ce pas très
du mont blanc comme jordi met nommément
mont-blanc l'année prochaine dans dix
ans d'un sens il sera toujours là
patienter une année mais je crois que
les gens se prennent un créneau de deux
trois jours pour venir faire l'ascension
du mont-blanc et coûte que coûte
on doit réussir l'ascension du monde au
risque de sa vie
harry fra - contre toute l'ue ccsn et il
est à la compagnie des guides de
chamonix on fait tout pour enseigner les
amoureux de la montagne tout pour les
aider à partir en randonnée mais aussi
tout pour dissuader ceux qui n'ont
vraiment pas le niveau
montons en mission de prévention
également pour le fils de haute montagne
ici avant de partir on étudie la météo
le bon équipement l'itinéraire on sait
que le risque zéro n'existe pas mais on
met tous les atouts de son côté
on peut réduire le risque au maximum en
préparant bien préparée bien la faire en
regardant les itinéraires ont donc se
renseigner sur la météo
après j'ai vu qu'ils sont faits prendre
aussi donc
la montagne ça reste dangereux on peut
pas maîtriser tous les paramètres en
trois jours onze personnes ont été
victimes de chutes mortelles dans les
alpes tué par imprudence ou par
malchance mais pour les amoureux de la
montagne cela reste onze morts de trop
le parquet de lyon a décidé de se
pourvoir en cassation contre l'arrêt
rendu hier par la cour d'appel qui
considèrent l'église de scientologie
comme une religion cette décision a
provoqué des réactions de la part de
tous ceux qui luttent contre la
prolifération des sectes en france mais
aussi la satisfaction des responsables
de l'antenne françaises de la
scientologie
jacques cardoze aniesa une caution
morale
voilà ce qu'ils ont gagné et c'est peut
être cela le plus important
car le plus dangereux dès aujourd'hui
les scientologues ont accepté de nous
ouvrir leurs portes mais à condition de
pouvoir développer un nouvel
argumentaire de bain extract c'est quand
même quelque chose qui va vraiment
changer beaucoup de choses non seulement
pour les scientologues qui vont pouvoir
vraiment participer encore plus dans la
société
mais la société elle-même va y retrouver
son compte parce qu'elle va pouvoir
gagner sur des secteurs que sur lesquels
elle avait des difficultés à ce qu'a dit
le juge c'est que la notion de secte n'a
aucun fondement juridique et que la
scientologie doit être donc considérée
comme une religion et doivent bénéficier
la protection qui est accordée aux
religions notamment par la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme faux la
scientologie n'a pas été reconnu comme
religion
en revanche elle peut revendiquer un
statut d'association cultuelle
problème danièle gounord directrice du
centre doit en faire la demande auprès
du ministère de l'intérieur
quelles sont ses intentions réponse
évasive la scientologie continue
d'avancer masqué nous allons fait ou va
continuer plus en paix les actions de
développement le prosélytisme et
j'espère s'adonner davantage à notre
route personnel l'amélioration plutôt
qu'un des guerres ou les procès inutiles
la justice a condamné à plusieurs
reprises la scientologie le tribunal de
commerce de paris lui réclame toujours
50 millions de francs une somme due au
fisc
a lyon un adepte de la secte a été
condamné pour homicide involontaire
une première d'autres procès sont en
cours pour escroquerie on est loin d'une
religion l'église de scientologie a
surtout de drôles de méthodes
elle a un organisme de renseignement une
espèce de police secrète elle recourt
aux menaces au chantage à l'extorsion à
l'escroquerie à l'intimidation
elle pratique ce qu'elle appelle la
propagande noire alors tout ça nous
entraîne très loin d'une église et
s'apparente plutôt à une association de
malfaiteurs par choix enfin en france la
scientologie ne pourraient bénéficier
d'exonérations fiscales que sur les dons
or sa principale ressource financière
provient de la vente de livres cassettes
et stages de formation
a marseille la enquête sur l'origine des
incendies devra déterminer la
responsabilité de l'entreprise qui a
déposé des déchets dans la décharge nous
est parti le feu responsabilité
également des propriétaires de la
décharge
parallèlement à cette affaire il ya un
an maintenant le préfet de région avait
mis sur pied une mission de spécialistes
de la sécurité civile et des eaux et
forêts chargé d'étudier ces problèmes de
départ de feu malheureusement très trop
nombreux l'été dans le sud de la france
les membres de cette mission sont
actuellement sur le terrain reportage
vincent nguyen emmanuel pec
comment le week-end dernier c'est sans
un secteur ont ils pu s'enflammer près
de salon-de-provence
c'est bien la question que se posent ces
cinq hommes dépêchés sur place
aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce que c'est là donc c'est
en train d'attaquer si première
hypothèse après enquête de voisinage
le feu serait parti accidentellement à
côté d'une maison et aurait sauté le
chemin pour attaquer la colline deuxième
hypothèse une mise à feu criminel un peu
plus son détecteur je vais le mettre la
terre du fus 6 mai à biper donc là il
n'habite pas donc a priori ce bidon
étaient présents avant l'incendié
et bah ne contenait pas de produits
inflammables au moment du départ du
sinistre
gendarmes pompiers policiers et
ingénieur des eaux et forêts travaillons
de concert
c'est une équipe expérimentale qui
pourrait devenir un modèle il est
certain que le forestier qui connaît
parfaitement ce qui a brûlé le pompier
c'est ce qui l'a vu quand il a brûlé le
policier le gendarme apporte ce qui vaut
au niveau de l' enquête le tout est
confronté en permanence ce qui est quand
même de loin le plus efficacement et
voici les gendarmes locaux qui avance
une troisième hypothèse le feu viendrait
en fait de cette décharge sauvage
continue à se consumer par dessous avec
la possibilité de ressortir ses
enquêteurs ne cherche pas de coupables
simplement des causes pour établir des
statistiques
si 80% des flots sont d'origine humaine
seulement 20% sont volontaires
on est tous vous moi on est tous
susceptibles d'être un incendiaire tout
à l'heure par négligence donc que ce
qu'on appelle une cause involontaire
c'est ce phénomène là qu'il faut traiter
en priorité car le but de cette
entreprise est de connaître au mieux le
feu de forêt pour anticiper les risques
soigner le mal à la racine
c'est jeudi que patrick weil chargé par
le gouvernement d'un rapport sur
l'immigration en france remettra ses
propositions au point ministre lionel
jospin on en connaît déjà quelques
grandes lignes notamment en ce qui
concerne l'acquisition de la nationalité
française pour les enfants de parents
étrangers la demande volontaire serait
maintenu et présenté à l'occasion du
nouveau rendez vous citoyen de 24 heures
florence bukina à partir des débats
patrick weil il a 40 ans il est
sociologue et le premier univers [ __ ]
chargé d'un dossier très délicat fut
celui de l'immigration le nez par le
premier ministre dès la déclaration de
politique générale le 10 juin dernier
patrick vailli doit rendre son rapport
jeudi prochain à lionel jospin un
rapport sur la refonte des lois pasqua
et du code de la nationalité
la philosophie de patrick weil redonner
à l'immigration aux places positive tout
d'abord en simplifiant les procédures
administratives pour certaines
catégories d'étrangers
ceux par exemple qui contribuent à
l'évolution de la société française
les étudiants les chercheurs les hommes
d'affaires leur statut serait facilitée
le droit d'asile
ils seraient accordés avec plus
d'harmonie entre la situation
géopolitique réelle du pays d'origine et
sont demandeurs
ainsi les algériens possibles victimes
dans leur pays non seulement des
islamistes mais aussi de leurs
gouvernements se verrait accorder plus
facilement une sorte d'asile
territoriales par contre les roumains
qui représente 23 % des demandes d'asile
politique
mais vivent maintenant dans un pays dit
démocrates n'obtiendraient plus et asie
enfin un point important le code de la
nationalité
patrick weil veut garder la
manifestation de volonté de devenir
français entre 16 et 18 ans mais à 18
ans ils ne se sont pas manifestés les
jeunes seront de toute façon convoqué
par l'armée est recensée ils auront
alors un an pour dire un éventuel refus
d'obtenir cette nationalité française et
seront sinon inscrits d'office sur les
listes électorales dans le différend qui
oppose le gouvernement aux maires qui
ont décidé de restreindre la circulation
des enfants de moins de
12 ans seul après minuit bien le conseil
d'état vient de trancher à propos de la
municipalité de sorgues suspendant
l'arrêté du maire
le tribunal administratif avait lui
refusé de trancher sur le front des
inondations maintenant dans l'est de
l'allemagne la situation s'est
stabilisée le chancelier helmut kohl a
interrompu aujourd'hui ses vacances en
autriche pour venir visiter les régions
sinistrées rendre visite aux soldats de
la bundeswehr qui luttent contre les
flots dans cette région de l'allemagne
de l'est
de l'autre côté de la frontière en
pologne la décrue s'est engagé
heureusement l'heure du premier bilan
est arrivée
reportage dans la ville devra clos sept
cent mille habitants au centre du pays
thierry curtet pierre emmanuel luneau
cinq jours sous l'eau le quartier a du
mal à s'en remettre
les polonais aussi 10% d'entre eux
seulement seront assurées ce sont eux
qui essuieront la plus grosse partie de
la note
25 milliards de francs les dégâts ne
sont pas tous apparent les canalisations
en fonte souliers la distribution
électrique noyé
il est avant l'escale à de l'eau jusque
là nous explique le vice directeur de
l'hôpital et il nous fait visiter le
rez-de-chaussée où était installé le
tomographe un appareil radiologique
sophistiquée qui faisait sa fierté
achetés grâce à une souscription des
habitants de la ville
il a été à moitié détruit il faudra
trois mois pour tout nettoyer
il faudra des infectés désinsectiseurs
et dératiser tout l'hôpital le dr
charrier produits chimiques et eaux
usées
les dépôts sont très toxiques dans la
cuisine centrale
comme partout ailleurs médecins et
infirmières sont côte à côte pour
nettoyer c'est la première urgence avant
toute autre chose
les 600 malades ont été évacuées alors
que lou était déjà dans l'hôpital on a
pensé qu'il fallait uniquement et
l'actuel au rez-de-chaussée celui des
patients en soins intensifs jour n'a pas
vraiment été averti que la situation
deviendrait aussi grave
une évacuation si tardive que trois
enfants gravement blessé n'ont pas pu
être évacués ils sont restés dans leur
chambre
durant toute la crue après la faillite
totale des prévisions de l'institut
météo polonais le maire d'auch paul une
ville encore plus touchée a décidé de
porter plainte
une grande première
officiellement les inondations ont fait
au moins 55 morts mais les polonais ont
appris à se méfier de tous et surtout
des chiffres officiels en france le
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports au
nom du gouvernement a décidé une aide
exceptionnelle de 500 mille francs à
destination des associations de
vitrolles priver de subventions par la
nouvelle mairie front national avant son
départ de la préfecture du var jean
charles marchiani le préfet aurait
décidé de porter plainte après la
découverte de faux tampons officiels de
la préfecture à la mairie de fréjus
dirigée par françois léotard celui ci
estime qu'il s'agit là d'un montage et
d'une farce ridicule le gouvernement
tiendra demain son dernier conseil des
ministres avant trois semaines de
vacances l'occasion pour nous de nous
intéresser à trois membres de l'ancien
gouvernement juppé qui sont partis eux à
la recherche d'un nouveau travail des
films des tris on n'est pas les éclopés
du suffrage universel je crois qu'il
faut pas prendre les choses
l avantage de la défaite c'est que c'est
une expérience dans laquelle on la prend
pour un peu on pourrait croire que les
anciens ministres l'ont facilement
encaissé sept défaites
pourtant ils l'avouent ça fait comme un
vide quand on n'a pas la chance d'être
député on est plutôt dépité le téléphone
ne sommes plus les sollicitations sont
moins nombreuses les voyages sont plutôt
entre votre domicile et l'amérique à
travers la france l'ancien ministre de
la ville se consacre désormais à sa
mairie du raincy en seine-saint-denis
treize mille habitants et autant de
petits problèmes à gérer autres
ministres battus autre fidèle de jacques
chirac l'ancien garde des sceaux
jacques toubon a trouvé refuge à
l'elysée comme conseiller du président
reconversion facile aussi pour corinne
lepage spécialiste de l'environnement
elle retrouve sa profession d'origine
sans amertume savez j'avais amitié avant
d'être ministre
ce mec qui m'a tant qu'avocat chez
juristes et donc et leur devenir
mais qu'il ministre et
mais qui est par définition éphémère il
faut donc trouver un point de chute
ancien fonctionnaire alain lamassoure
fait mine d'hésiter
mais l'ex ministre du budget a tout de
même une petite idée période pour avoir
une expérience professionnelle nouvelles
notamment dans l'entreprise privée de
manière à mieux connaître de l'intérieur
les problèmes de l'entreprise
les anciens ministres ont quatre mois
pour réussir leur sortie
quatre mois pendant lesquels ils tentent
encore leur indemnité à vergèze dans le
gard cool la source perrier l'un des
principaux employeurs de la ville
racheté il ya cinq ans par le groupe
nestlé qui envisage un troisième plan de
restructuration qui supprimerait
directement ou indirectement 700 emplois
environ car inkomazi pascal pons perrier
vergèze une histoire d'eau et d'emploi
qui dure depuis presque cent ans ici
l'annoncé de la suppression de près de
400 postes a été un choc pour les
villageois
il assure supérieur venu affirmer cela
quatre ans soit vaut mieux bien sûr mais
là il était ici si oui c'est aussi le
goût du matin le fameux sont encore dans
les hommes pareils tous nos mêmes
parlent le projet de réorganisation du
site qui en jargon de multinationales
signifie ni plus ni mois un plan social
prévoit la suppression de 380 emplois à
l'extraction et à l'emballage mais pour
réduire les coûts de production la
direction ne s'arrête pas là notre
objectif c'est de se recentrer sur notre
coeur de métier qui est la fabrication
du perrier l'embouteillage du perrier
pour ça nous allons externalisées et
confiées à des entreprises spécialistes
nos activités qui ne sont pas celles de
notre coeur de métier comme par exemple
la restauration le nettoyage le
gardiennage et la fabrication des pales
est un recentrage qui sonne comme une
promesse de licenciement pour les 360
employés concernés par ces transferts
mais pour nestlé propriétaire de la
source perrier doit retrouver une bonne
santé financière
mais la vérité que perrier vittel à
travers les rivaux en réalité nous
licencier pour des tas de raisons qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'économie et la
santé financière de notre entreprise à
faire au plus de fric avec deux plans
sociaux 800 emplois supprimés en cinq
ans la direction du groupe nestlé assure
qu'il s'agit là d'un ultime
réorganisation loin de veuves et le
siège de la multinationale suisse des
rejets inquiète attend le départ de 700
salariés avec ton était international
pour la première fois depuis 18 ans elle
et téléspectateurs américains ont pu
revoir le visage de polpot l'ex
dictateur sanguinaire du cambodge un
document exclusif diffusé donc par une
télévision américaine que de nombreux
cambodgiens réfugié aux états unis ont
regardé avec toujours le même effroi
jean-marc il ose ce visage de vieillard
fatigué en exclusivité hier soir à la
télévision américaine et celui de
l'assassin de leur famille et de 2
millions de leurs concitoyens celui de
polpot l'orchestrateur du génocide
cambodgien
sophie et sa famille cambodgien réfugié
aux états unis comptent parmi les rares
évadés des camps de la mort khmère rouge
hier soir il avait du mal à croire que
c'était bien là le bourreau de leurs
peuples des mois je n'arrivais pas
partie puis n'a vraiment être un être
humain
maintenant je vois bien qu'après avoir
presque tué son pays il est vraiment
vivant de personnes mais que rien
entre 1975 et 79 les khmers rouges de
pol pot avait remplacé un régime pro
américain corrompu par une dictature
nationale maoïstes et envoyé trois
millions de leurs concitoyens aux
travaux forcés polpot synonyme de
terreur absolue pour les cambodgiens
aurait donc été jugé récemment par ses
anciens compagnons mais dans des
conditions qui sont encore loin d'être
clair aujourd'hui terrer dans le
nord-ouest où rallié comme ceux ci les
khmers rouges ne sont plus un danger
militaire
mais leur chef entendent bien marchander
ce qu'il leur est d' influence contre
une nouvelle légitimité
après tout beaucoup de dirigeants du
cnom peine actuelle sont aussi d'anciens
alliés
autant dire qu'un véritable procès
n'arrangerait personne et que la
question khmer rouge reste explosive
pour la stabilité du cambodge
wendy pays frontalier du rwanda et de
l'ancien zaïre alors que l'attention du
monde était focalisée sur la déchéance
du président mobutu les autorités
tutsies qui dirige le burundi se sont
livrés discrètement à une élimination et
des déportations de population où tout
reportage dorothée olliéric frédéric
parce que le camp de m
banda a des allures de casernes à une
demi heure de route de la capitale
bujumbura quelques 7000 août où vivent
ici regroupés comme dit le gouvernement
souvent contre leur gré ils sont sous la
protection de nombreux militaires tous
officiellement c'est pour leur sécurité
mais les organisations humanitaires
dénoncent une stratégie de recomposition
est luc l'armée contre les paysans à
quitter leurs collines
s'ils refusent ils sont considérés comme
rebelle et risque d'être abattu à vue
pour garder le camp le chef n'est pas ce
que vous êtes combien
il n'y a pas de problème de sécurité ici
les militaires n'ont pas l'autorisation
de nous parler quand aux réfugiés ils
craignent d'en dire trop
les enfants ont peur d'être filmés et
les adultes qui parle de folie bout des
lèvres d'un rester c'est en vain promène
et de préférence allait avec le
militaire donc vous pouvez pas retourner
dans votre village mais vous aimeriez
retournez dans votre village à deux
heures de route de mpanda seront d'être
cueille des centaines de réfugiés eux ne
craignez pas les militaires tutsis mais
les bandes armées nous tous au burundi
les hutus assassine les tutsi se venge
et les massacres de civils se
multiplient sont témoins alors par peur
ils sont restés des moins serré dans la
forêt
les miliciens hutus
q plein de gens c'est pour ça que j'ai
quitté la forêt se passe la nuit ils
attaquent des familles endormi de vrai
massacre
ils tuent et ils disparaissent regroupés
dans des camps de fortune sans maison et
sans avenir
ces hommes et ces femmes doivent vivre
avec des étiquettes assaillants
sympathisants d'assaillants ou citoyens
innocents
on savait que les femmes enceintes qui
fument risque de fragiliser la vie de
leur bébé une étude américaine tendrait
à prouver désormais que les pères
fumeurs sont également un danger pour
leur futur enfant
gilles marini les méfaits du tabac sont
transmissibles
il n'est pas rare de retrouver des
traces de nicotine dans les cheveux d'un
bébé jusqu'à présent l'homme pouvait
croire que la responsabilité en
incombait à sa compagne eh bien c'est
fini
ce que cet article confirme c'est que le
risque du tabagisme pour le futur enfant
dépend non seulement de la mer mais
également du père l'a découverte en
effet c'est que le tabac c'est le grand
fumeur masculin s'attaque aux
chromosomes modifions le capital
génétique transmis à l'enfant via les
spermatozoïdes
un bouleversement qui n'apporte rien de
bon ces altérations vont lors de la
fécondation bien entendu pouvoir
modifier certains fonctionnement
cellulaire du futur enfant et induire
non pas directement un cancer mais
vraisemblablement une susceptibilité une
fragilité vis-à-vis de la survenue d'un
cancer ou d'une leucémie une carrière
marquée par le tabac avant même leur
première cigarette ils ne tomberont
heureusement pas tous malades
le risque est réel mais faible il serait
même selon les scientifiques carrément
nulles si le futur père qu'on se le dise
qu'on sentait à cesser de fumer au nom
avant d'engendrer un enfant est
maintenant l'ordinateur au service des
femmes enceintes dans une
nick de nice les mamans sur le point
d'accoucher sont reliés à un ordinateur
qui lui-même prévient les sages femmes
de service afin d'éviter tout retard ou
toute forme de complications reportage
olivier terre marie france est en salle
de travail sous péridurale elle va
accoucher dans une heure ou deux autour
d'elles s'est mise en place toute la
logistique de suivi médical
le monitoring permet aux gynécologues et
aux sages-femmes de suivre les
battements du coeur du bébé et les
contractions en temps réel la nouveauté
c'est que grâce à un réseau informatique
le praticien peut suivre en même temps
les futures mamans qui sont dans les
cinq autres salles d'accouchement à voir
c'était pas possible on devra alors
étendu il devrait se répartir on trouve
à envoyer quelqu'un survie etc
maintenant quand même on peut
on peu surveillés de beaucoup plus près
et donc l prêt à tout moment à répondre
à une situation non pas de stress comme
avant mais d'urgence médicale qu'on peut
qu'on peut gérer ce système unique en
europe a été développé spécialement par
hewlett-packard à la demande du service
maternité de la clinique saint georges
l'innovation après un mois d'essai est
très apprécié par les sages-femmes et
les nouvelles mamans
premièrement passionne on a toujours
l'écran sous les yeux quel que soit
l'endroit où ils se trouvent et
deuxièmement en cas de deux tracés
pathologique l'appareil nous signale
qu'il y a un problème c'est à dire qu'il
ya une alarme chose qui n'existait pas
avant
c'est c'est grâce à l'ordinateur c'est
très rassurant de savoir que l'équipe
est présente à chaque instant même si
elle n'est pas dans la pièce et malgré
tout on à préserver la tranquillité de
la naissance 200 bébés naissent tous les
mois dans ce service depuis quelques
jours il arrive au monde ont des
conditions de sécurité et de confort
encore plus important
l'informatique s'installe au chevet des
nouvelles lui après la catastrophe du
drac la rivière qui souvenez-vous avait
emporté une classe d'enfants de grenoble
après un lâcher d'eau d'un barrage edf
electricité de france a décidé de
disposer sur le terrain des brigades de
jeunes chargés d'alerter les touristes
sur les risques qu'ils prennent en
confondant parfois le lit des rivières
avec les berges
reportage dans la région de chambéry
alexandre kara olivier robert depuis le
début de l'été ses petites voitures
bleues sillonnent les alpes et plus
précisément les rivières en aval des
barrages des zones dangereuses
nicolas et étudiants est dit est au
chômage et comme 150 autres jeunes
saisonniers ils ont accepté d'endosser
les couleurs d'edf
leur mission rencontrer nos vacanciers
imprudent pour leur rappeler qu'à tout
moment à lâcher d'eau feu maître de leur
existence en péril ce qu'ils appellent à
lâcher ou est bon vous êtes
tranquillement en train de vous baigner
et vous vous retrouvez avec une grosse
vague qui vous tombe sur le point de
jouer et vous avez beau être des supers
nageurs
elle vous embarque la vague une
opération de prévention de proximité
entamé depuis deux ans par edf pour que
ne se reproduise jamais la tragédie du
drac nous n'ont pas attendu le drame
pour sensibiliser la population
effectivement nous avons tiré les leçons
de ce drame et on a en pitié
notre action de sensibilisation en
allant au devant du public
une opération de charme généralement
appréciée par le public mais il ya
toujours des mauvaises têtes c'est que
bon on paye le dr
et puis en plus sont en vacances et on
peut pas se baigner on peut pas faire ce
qu'on veut on tombait malheureusement
sur une famille de récalcitrants qui ont
déjà eu l'information deux jours
auparavant et qui se croient
malheureusement en dehors de l'étranger
le danger existe bien le drame du drac
l'a prouvé mais ce en collaboration avec
les collectivités locales
la marge de manoeuvre d'edf reste faible
il faut espérer pourtant que cette
campagne ne sera pas qu'un simple coup
d'épée dans l'eau
le chanteur pascal obispo annuler la
suite de sa tournée en corse hier soir
ajaccio lui et un de ses musiciens ont
reçu une volée de plombs tirés par un
spectateur qui visiblement était
mécontent de s'être vu refuser l'entrée
du spectacle et de blessés n'ont été que
légèrement touchés et l'agresseur arrêté
nous parlions en ce début de journal des
dangers de la montagne embête sommes une
région très fréquentée par les touristes
en été mais également dangereuse en
raison de la rapidité des marais
gendarmes maîtres nageurs effectué des
surveillance permanente à bord
d'hélicoptères and mourgues patrick dur
ça
c'est vrai que c'est beau on voit assez
calme et puis d'un seul coup on va ça
arrive on peut pas quoi c'est ça que le
problème ce qu'on peut pas savoir que
une mère peut arriver comme un cheval au
galop
seul au milieu de la plage cet homme n'a
pas conscience du danger
il est normalement interdit de se
promener ici à marée montante
tout l'été pour éviter les noyades un
hélicoptère de la gendarmerie sillonnent
la baie le plomb est bon temps voyez
dégager les lieux
il évacue les touristes inconscients les
gens sont imprudents à marée monte très
rapidement et vous en cercle et vous
laisse sur des bancs de sable vous isole
sur des bancs de sable
un hélicoptère pour surveiller la plage
de la baie de somme
mais aussi une sirène trois coups avant
la marée montante des panneaux sur le
rivage perché en haut du phare à maître
nageur surveille les imprudents trois
heures et demie avant la pleine mer ils
doivent être montées mais beaucoup de
gens tarder parce que comme vous voyez
les conditions nos séries qui sont
bonnes donc ils se promènent et puis les
gens sont en vacances en fait depuis le
début de l'été l'hélicoptère a évacué
plus de 200 touristes aucune noyade à
déplorer mais les efforts d'information
ne sont pas toujours récompensés
vous savez c'est précisément pourquoi
c'est dangereux non je ne sais pas les
gens viennent pour deux trois jours dans
la zone donc en fait la population se
renouvelle en permanence et à chaque
fois il faut recommencer le message
informez évacuer si nécessaire il y a
quelques jours les gendarmes ont même
délogé un campeur attirés par la beauté
du site
il avait planté sa tente au milieu de la
baie pour y passer la nuit
la 28e édition de la solitaire du figaro
à la voile partira demain d'arcachon
pour arriver le 22 août prochain à
saint-quay-portrieux 51 concurrents au
départ parmi des grands philippe poupon
florence arthaud mais aussi marc
thiercelin deuxième du dernier vendée
globe un marin à part poète et peintre à
ses heures
christophe duchiron vincent meyer on dit
en général qu'un dessin vaut mieux qu'un
long discours pour parler des marins
solitaires c'est parfois vrai il vendée
globe bouclé en 113 jours martyrs se la
ramener des dessins deuxième de la
course
il possède forcément beaucoup de bars
mais il a aussi un bon coup de crayon
bateaux sur l'eau peintures à laon il ya
des marins qui peuvent voir les dessins
d'enfants en peinture pendant quelques
années
pire cela était illustrateur de mode
pour kenzo d'autres sites et avant de
partir un jour autour du monde je pars
traçait le sillage de mauvais tour du
monde pour mieux retrouver la terre et
ses habitants
j'espère que tout aura changé comme
l'enfant procédé grandir en novembre 96
pressé de partir il s'en allait pour le
vendée globe en juin de cette année il
était entouré d'enfants dans le sud de
la france des enfants qui l'ont suivi
dans son aventure
il a même retrouvé une petite adèle qui
de lui envoyer un fax un jour d'hiver
alors qu'il naviguait dans le grand sud
ça me fait rigoler parce que de son
propre concours initiatives écrit comme
ça 9 ans et demi moi j'étais en plein
milieu du pacifique agir c'est sympa
aussi
c'est un peu avant l'histoire de geely
ça m'a fait plaisir j'ai bien c'est que
il est lisse qaeda dadis très sociaux et
ça c'est moi je préfère ça que quelqu'un
qui dit oui c'est moi oui c'est moi qui
essaient de vendée globe quatre mois
après le vendée globe
pierre cela a remis son costume de marin
pour la solitaire du figaro
le bateau ne mesure que neuf mètres et
chacune des quatre étapes ressemble un
sprint de trois ou quatre jours deux
épreuves tellement différente mais sur
l'eau thiercelin poursuit toujours un
seul et même but
je voudrais pas c'est ce que j'essaye de
plus du tout aux jeunes de faire passer
ma passion aux autres véhicules et
susciter des vocations d'avoir de plus
en plus de gens qu'ils vont vers la mer
surtout qu'ils vont sur la mer qui
découle ce que ce monde d'accord
en plus des dessins et des croquis
marque à conserver les cartes de son
père y
cent treize jours de mer qu'ils ont
transformé le tour du monde a fait de
marc thiercelin citoyens des mers un
homme des océans
un marin public qui a conservé une âme
d'enfant il a aujourd'hui 37 ans est
chez lui sous la pluie de bretagne il
aime sans doute se souvenir qu'ils les
tamarins pas tout à fait comme les
autres
l'aviron magna bat son plein en ce
moment richard virenque deuxième du tour
de france héros de la montagne connaît
une popularité exceptionnelle auprès du
public hier soir le champion était à
lisieux pour un critérium d'après-tour
trente mille personnes étaient venues
l'applaudir cyrille devaud patrick des
chemins car il a suffi qu'il apparaisse
pour déchaîner la pelouse une foule de
30 mille personnes qui n'avaient d'yeux
que pour richard virenque richard
dauphin du tour de france mais roi
incontestable du critérium de lisieux
ray charles populaire mélange de
poulidor et de michael jackson richard
la star impressionnant de chance 10 ans
on étouffait dans les rangs horrible
j'ai failli me faire vieux qui ne cite
personne n'échappe à l'aviron magna en
un mois riesch à a reçu plus de 25 mille
lettres de fans alors richard se
retranche dans sa chambre d'hôtel pour
échapper aux photographes heures et fuir
les autographes sans y parvenir
mes affaires sont souvent tâcher de
de stylos de fait parce que quand je
passe dans la foulée je me fais jeter
dessus et c'est assez impressionnant à
chaque star sa marque de fabrique depuis
quatre ans richard à la sienne le
maillot à pois du meilleur grimpeur en
guise de costumes à paillettes une image
de marque qui se négocie vire entre
emploie 69 ans de cachet pour s'aligner
au départ du critérium pour disputer un
contre la montre individuel et une
course en circuit
pour la petite histoire richard termine
deuxième derrière le champion de france
stéphane barthe deuxième comme au tour
de france décidément les héros
malheureux sont toujours mille fois plus
sympathique
à cordes l'une des plus belles villes
médiévales de france dans le département
du tarn
un luthier parisien s'est installé là il
ya quelques années ses principaux
clients lui sont restés fidèles et ses
relations lui ont permis d'organiser
cette année un premier festival sous
forme de rencontres entre le fabricant
d'instruments à cordes et les musiciens
bruno albin maryse richard
aux confins du pays cathare il ya un
magicien des sons un luthier
cet été les jeunes musiciens viennent à
lui une semaine de concerts et de
rencontres entre jeunes instrumentistes
français facteurs d'instruments européen
et mélomanes
m
à cordes
on peut donc visiter l'atelier des juifs
rencontrer les interprètes et mieux
comprendre pourquoi les uns le peuple se
passer des autres on n'avait pas de
soucis d'état d'angoise l'impression que
lyon ça ne sonne pas bien l'impression
que l'archer tordu et cesser d angoisse
qu'on a tous les jours qui d'un coup
d'avoir des luthiers comme ça à côté
nous c'est formidable parce qu'on peut
interlocuteur direct pour une fois qu'on
peut avoir une permanence comme comme il
ya des permanences de médecins d'un
lance de notices c'est formidable
pour les musiciens ces rencontres sont
aussi l'occasion de jouer des
instruments de facture moderne comme ce
violon sortie des mains du luthier de
corde le japon outil est important comme
ça je pourrais tient au fait les
secondes et pour le musicien
c est le premier à le jouer c'est à dire
il va donner son la sonorité instruments
sont en fait c'est au nom de ces chats
cloutier en son centre
mais le musicien pas ce qui fait la
souris
l'expérience dure le temps du festival
de corde jusqu'au 2 août
après le départ des artistes il restera
cette passionnante leçon de choses
une nouvelle façon d'apprécier la
musique
dans quelques instants la météo de
nathalie rihouet dernier journal 10h30
florence dauchez demain 13h patrick
chêne quant à moi je vous retrouverai à
20 heures je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir
m